Jacob Decker Rob handler II that's right
and we are here take a look at V new
patch 1.07 we have a list here kind of
take a look at each one of these first
up we got a new movement mechanic I
think this is probably the biggest one
yeah [ __ ] I went to the wrong thing so I
guess there have been some complaints on
like kind of you know the response of
Gerald's movement so this is on right
now it's on right now it the animations
don't look as real I mean right now they
look row so I'm just going in a straight
line but when you start to like turn
around to kind of kind of loses some of
that realistic look but it does it does
I can it does play a little bit better
I'd say it's hard to visually see then
probably play yourself I don't really
feel it yeah I mean I don't know if
you'll notice much of a difference in
combat - it just kind of seems like the
moving around is what does it yeah
but they also apparently Roach is
supposed to be as right useless useless
and I mean my my opinion the main issue
would be whatever he spawned she could
live one time he like spawned in the
building and I came up just been having
a drink in here yeah he's quite the
horse yeah I don't know I can't tell the
difference yeah what else we have here
so there are new stashes for items
across the map correct so if you go to
the map they show up is little these
little green things right so there's a
couple of them yeah one in novigrad it
looks like taking a look at this stash
in this building here looks like
little green okay oh this is a sultan oh
whoa
straight-up so I'm assuming it's this
thing yeah - let's drop some stuff in
here all right so just more grids all
right I guess that works
cool stash some pants in there
cool let's move along here book tabs oh
those look am books
I can finally sort all my books thank
God
so yeah if you go into inventory and you
switch over on the wrong way to go to
inventory you switch over to this new
last tab and it is just simply books and
I there you go you got all your
documents your books so you can just sit
there and read all that and reheat it's
all in one spot and it looks like the
ones that you have read are great out
there
so try reading also notes as well so you
open up a note and it's gonna gray out
cool and then um let's see here also
alchemy ingredients now way nothing oh
this is a good ones yeah BAM so they
should have a game so yeah zero zero
zero zero zero just zeros for days I
have an idea why you just when you try
spawning Roach here okay see what
happens just taking a little swim taking
a little dip oh all right well you know
whatever that's good I always get a
light chuckle out of roach she's kind of
like a comic relief for this game
sometimes cool so how about there's
another one here just like generic
inventory like sorting just want to pull
up inventory again I'm curious yeah I
got about this I'm not entirely sure
what it sort items so click okay l-3
they're tight there we go
that's that cool is really cool I didn't
think it was that specific I was gonna
be like weapon classes like swords but
it's like durability
in price through the outcoming also you
could you could even sell look at that
price so you just go through and be like
oh man let me sell all this hot hot [ __ ]
that's pretty cool
bet I love a cooler than I thought cuz
the inventory is kind of a mess in this
game it still is a mess even with all
this to be honest but it does certainly
does certainly help it kind of eases the
pain of going through all this
definitely cool well that looks like for
the most part all the major additions
also of course there are other fixes and
such but um wait they fix a lot of like
little glitches and issues like that but
yeah those are those are the biggest
ones this is a big update I think it was
like almost eight gigs 7.5 at least on
least on PlayStation I don't know OPM is
I'm assuming probably around the same
though yeah that's cool yeah the sorting
was was probably the biggest for me and
books hook tab is pretty great too
because those things are getting
annoying but cool Jake alright that's it
you guys take care now